this is weird
like really weird conference for node
man so I actually have nothing
interesting to say I don't do anything
interesting these days I just fix bugs
and try to progress node you know
there's there's a lot of work to do and
so I'm just going to talk about what is
happening in the next version it's okay
with you okay it's going to be extremely
you can like go get coffee if you want I
will not be offended I wanted to do a
more interesting talk but yeah alright
so first of all well I just put this
slide in here because it's it's somewhat
amazing like node seems to be attracting
a lot of people to it there are 4,000
people on the mailing list and if you go
in the IRC at noon on Pacific Standard
time you'll see 600 people idling there
it is kind of a lot of people there's
books and several books coming out I
guess the Japanese book is going to be
the first one it's 500 pages and will
probably be done I don't know when is it
going to be done guys like a month end
of June okay
of course most of us can't read it but
we can look at it and it'll be pretty
top is working on a book I think there's
there's some others in the works there's
there's translations in the various
languages and we are spamming hacker
news all the time
because I don't know we like to click
the up button
okay so May 2009 initial release then we
did the first stable release which was
zipped to in late 2010 and we just came
out with 0 4 which kind of had a bumpy
first few versions and is still a bit
bumpy with with SSL and stuff but it's
getting better starting to feel kind of
good about the new stuff that went into
0 4 so 0 4 was all about fixing SSL and
doing HTTP and
hello didn't anybody hear what I just
said
no okay so zero for I mean the main
focus was fixing the HTTP client
interface and fixing the and and doing
SSL properly with much thanks to Paul
Clara and a lot of other people who
worked on this so zero five is is our
next unstable release which we're
already working on and the the stable
release will be zero six and that will
be in about two to three months
hopefully so the goal of this basically
is windows compatibility we are taking
it very seriously to which you know most
of you people with all your glowing
icons out there on your laptops I see
you probably don't care so much because
the typical response from web
programmers is like what windows I mean
who uses that but actually believe it or
not I'm sure some of you believe it that
Windows does account for a large number
of the computers in the world in
particular servers there are a lot of
what's that exchange thing yeah mail
thing that that windows people use 33%
of servers according to Wikipedia we
want that market like for node to really
be a game it's total world domination we
have to target that that audience it's
it's not it's not acceptable to just
ignore that and continue onwards so we
do have a Windows port currently but
it's it's cygwin and nobody likes cygwin
everybody hates it it's just kind of
something that you do to get by and it's
buggy and it's slow and you wouldn't
really run a server off of cygwin but
you know it's a nice stopgap
to help the windows people get going but
from what I hear it's much better to
just spin up a VMware instance of Lenox
and run node there rather than in cygwin
that's not real that's not a real
Windows port so question I guess a
reasonable question is is it even
possible to do decent servers in Windows
like obviously like the the rest of the
OS is so awful like it would not be
surprising that you know it is just
simply impossible to write a decent
server and by decent you know I mean
could handle 10,000 idle connections and
not you know just churn and spin to
death right so it is possible actually
Microsoft does have smart people and
they do have you know fairly advanced
techniques and in the in the api's but
it's not the same as unit and I think
that's why a lot of software doesn't
actually make the make the jump from
from UNIX to to Windows we are going to
make the jump so in UNIX
a good server software would mean that
you do non-blocking sockets and that you
use a constant time io multiplexer like
KQ or eople like this is the definition
of this is what you must do on UNIX
systems to create a reasonable server
Windows has the the UNIX e select but
it's not constant time and that means
like when you load it up with with save
more than a hundred file descriptors it
becomes slow it doesn't scale with the
number of sockets that you want to load
on this right your your your polling for
for file system state for file
descriptor state changes and it just it
can't do that in a reasonable amount of
time
has to scan over all these sockets all
the time so they also have this thing
called WUSA event select which is better
in that it's it's it doesn't have the
the same properties of having to scan
all the file descriptors every time but
the the pulling mechanism which is WS a
wait for multiple events these people
and their names and is actually limited
to 64 file descriptors per threat and
they're actually not file descriptors
here handles 64 sockets per per threat
great yeah good choice like what what
why 64 sockets per thread like no we
want 20,000 like this is ridiculous so
that's awesome
right so at which point you learn these
things and you're just like well I guess
to our server is going to suck on
Windows you know but we are nerds and so
we we we get into reading documentation
for long periods of time and you find
out that it is actually possible to
write really good servers on Windows
with something called IO completion
ports
it's just that IO completion ports don't
act the same way it's it's not the same
concept as what you have in Unix in Unix
you are as I said you're waiting for
file descriptor state changes so you're
waiting for you know that socket to
become readable so that you can read
from it doing a non-blocking read or
you're waiting for that socket to become
writable because you've got a big buffer
of stuff to dump to it in Windows in in
IO completion ports it's rather that you
write to the socket and you get told
when it's done so the the kernel manages
the the send buffer for you and when you
want to read from the socket you just
read full you give it a buffer you read
from it and then you go away
calls you back in the future so somehow
it's a higher level interface iocp also
supports pipes which is cool but
whatever but regular files is is really
interesting so you can actually do have
real asynchronous file IO in in the
kernel on Windows and not have to do
these tricks
so if you're familiar with how we do
this in in node we also do a synchronous
file IO but we have to hack it so we we
have userspace threads that we execute
system calls in which is I mean totally
stupid but there there's no way to get
around that in UNIX um so one for one
one point for Windows right the good
thing is that nodes API as as we present
it to users is already iocp Masek or
whatever is already iocp ish so so you
you do write to a socket and you get a
callback when it's done you just receive
data from from sockets so you don't have
this kind of interface where you're
you're polling for file system for for
file descriptor state changes what does
that mean it means that we can probably
rework the plumbing without changing the
user facing API so it's likely that 0/6
won't have any API changes or if so
relatively minor ones that we just have
to fix but rather the whole the whole
plumbing will be reworked to deal with
this there have been some other attempts
to create a server library that works on
both UNIX and Windows but somehow none
of them are acceptable Libby V which we
use in in node currently does is very
UNIX II it's a perfect perfect
abstraction over UNIX IO multiplexers on
Windows however it just doesn't have it
you know Libby V is all about file
descriptors and if they're readable or
write a book it doesn't pour it on to
unto iocp you can run Libby v on select
on Windows but as we said before that's
that's somewhat unacceptable
there's live event so lib event - did
some plumbing of their own and now runs
on iocp on Windows but at least one
person pointed out in a in a mailing
list post that it's really bad like I
don't know
you can push like between two two
sockets you can push like 100 megabits
or something like through the loop back
like the it doesn't seem like they've
done a very good job of doing that like
they they did a lot of work to sit on
top of IOC P but somehow they they
didn't achieve actual speed so fail um
it also also a live event doesn't it
doesn't deal with it's only dealing with
sockets right and then there's boost
ASIO which is this c++ monstrosity you
know you you have to download it it's
about 60 megabytes of source code and
like it's just so many files and so much
api apparently it does work though they
do actually give you a poll on Lennox
and iocp on on Windows but it's just so
massive and it's just like seriously is
this such a hard problem like all I want
to do is like write to a socket like
this is this is not such a difficult
problem that we really require three
hundred files and twelve thousand
semicolons is what i WC gelled so it
also doesn't support regular files this
is all crap like the it's not all crap
but it's it's just not acceptable for
what we want to do
and I just think the problem is is not
that hard especially on now that we have
Libby V on on UNIX which is a very sort
of thin layer we can use Libby Beyond on
UNIX to prop up this system and it's
done you know most of the work for us
for most of the operating systems and
then on Windows we have iocp and so we
just need to make like a little layer
over that so that's this thing it's
called lib Ohio it was called lib oh
well and I think we'll change the name
again just to just to confuse everybody
because nobody will actually use it so
currently this this is being done in a
separate repository than node but that's
just to kind of maintain purity we want
all of our tests to B and C and we want
to make sure that we're not you know
tempted to jump into some laughs
loveliness and you know use node to do
the testing and stuff we want all this
this to be very pure and and just
dealing with with the C system so it's
actually working the the TCP socket and
server stuff basically is more or less
working yeah there's some there's
probably some bugs still so so we're
writing a lot of tests and actually I
would like to ask if you are interested
in in system programming or you're
you're somehow interested in this
problem a great way to get involved with
lib Ohio is to go in there and write a
test I mean the tests are huge because
they're C and you have to set up servers
and stuff and it's it's not incredibly
fun but but we do need some the the main
point of this is is that we have two
different implementations and so testing
is everything in this system so since we
have the the socket stuff the TCP socket
stuff worked out more or less we're
probably going to be dropping this into
node master very soon now like next week
which will just destroy everything but
that's okay
Bert builder of of cloud kick is is
doing the windows side and I'm doing the
UNIX side so here's here's the nice
architectural diagram it's actually not
that nice um but it should be in two
squares right because one's representing
Windows and one's representing UNIX and
whatever but you get the point is is
that iocp is kind of a higher level
interface then then what UNIX provides
it's it's somehow more abstract and so
we we kind of are sitting on top of that
and on on UNIX we have to kind of shim
that up with some extra libraries the
Libby B and libo i/o so the goal of this
is to avoid if def help we don't want
the entire source code of node to just
be littered with these preprocessor
branches that you know have different
implementations of every function the
goal is to push all the platform and
compatibility into this live Oh IO well
as much as makes sense obviously like we
don't want to get crazy about this but
let's get crazy a little bit we'll push
push it all down and then the the so
we'll have all the the platform stuff
into the this C library and then the
binding layer and the JavaScript stuff
should in the end be completely
cross-platform
ideally that's not the case right now so
if you look at the net dot J I told you
guys this would be a very boring talk I
am
I apologize I'm sure there will be like
very nice
I think sub stack made a Markov
generating rap IRC log thing this will
be fun
yes so we will avoid if deaf hell
another component of Windows is that
Windows users don't typically have
compiler tool chains so so we want to
distribute executables and one thing
that we've tried very hard in node is
not to dynamically link to everything in
the entire system although you know you
give it to the Debian package maintainer
x' and they're like static linking you
guys are idiots let's tear this apart um
Debian God so I'm glad that's being some
applause um there's probably one guy
that's like a Debian package Minturn
node you know they call our executable
nodejs instead of node because there's
some like ham-radio node executable know
we will get node okay the ham-radio
thing can change its name so right on
windows have you ever downloaded putty
it's like an exe file so beautiful like
I love that you just download it you run
it it works that is basically what we
will be able to do on Windows possibly
if we're if we're careful so I would
like to get to the state where we
literally distribute a exe file and
people can download that and now they
have note yes
it will be a nice user experience for
the windows people npm the package
manager are has a concept of building
add-ons right if you download I can't
even think of a library now something
you know there's all these add-ons it
will run through some GCC commands right
Windows users don't like to do that they
want binary stuff and actually a lot of
UNIX users also want binary stuff so
Isaac's been working on augmenting the
the package repository to store binary
compiled versions of the add-ons
that most people will be able to
download and just get a a pre pre
compiled dll and something that I really
want is long stack traces which I won't
go into what that is basically stack
traces that span events when you hit an
exception this will point of contention
yes so the primary thing that's
preventing us from doing that is that we
need entry points from the event loop
into JavaScript and we need to know
where all of those are and we need to
have a hook that is unified so that we
can do stuff there and currently it's
just spattered around the the system
it's just very hard to organize it we
don't have kind of a single entry point
where we can say okay now we are leaving
Libby B and going into into JavaScript
land
so with this plumbing reworking in mind
we know that we want that and so we will
take special care to to get these hooks
in there and as I said we don't want to
go the Libby B Lib event to path so you
know if we can't get gigabit throughput
over the loopback with the pair of TCP
sockets and have like 10,000 idle
connections on a on a server on every OS
then then clearly we have failed so
hopefully we that will not be the case
so we're trying to do benchmarking and
testing early on in the development of
this of this library so that we're not
so we don't like wake up in like you
know a year after our big refactor
somebody mails the mailing list and it
says oh I did this benchmark and it's
terrible no so hopefully we will know
where we're doing that is the end of my
talk you can ask me questions
so the question is are there any big
things that I that we have to give up in
order to do windows no actually not what
we have to do I mean the big thing that
we have to do is is we have to push some
of this code that's written in
JavaScript now the Lib Lib net-lib KS
into Sealand and it's unclear right now
if jumping between the c++ boundary and
javascript which we will possibly be
doing more of with this new binding
because whatever that that may affect
performance but we really won't know
until we get there but otherwise I mean
the the binding is very thin that we're
not we're not doing a bunch of magic
stuff here so we're just kind of
massaging the api's into place so no I
confidently so the question is have I
thought much about what comes after
windows compatibility yeah I mean there
there's there's some more stuff we need
to do still in particular there there
there's a lot of cleanup stuff that
needs to happen but we are quickly
approaching a stable thing so there's
not a ton of reworking this I want to do
this thing now because this is going to
basically be rewriting node we have a
lot of tests now so we can kind of with
some confidence say that we're going to
actually make it but I yeah we're
quickly approaching a 1.0 I don't worry
about it I mean one thing I've learned
is that like if you're not I mean we
will make every effort to make every
piece of core API work on both systems
in the most decent way oh by the way the
question was how can you prepare for
Windows API blah
just just hold off right I mean we might
just crash and burn here and the world
might explode so I mean don't worry
about it yet Hey hopefully hopefully
Scripps will just port over forward
slashes windows can deal with those it's
not it's not the worst thing on earth
that's not that's not the the path
problem is like the least of Windows
differences what's the next big thing
after Windows so just very vaguely I
think that that we need some some system
of connecting nodes together and kind of
managing multiple nodes and opening
channels between them that sort of thing
what are the the biggest problems people
have with node is that your question a
lot of people come to it and say people
can't program like this this is
impossible like this this outside in
word whatever spaghetti programming
style is is impossible to program in I
think those people haven't actually sat
down and like tried to write a program
or gotten deeply into it and I don't
think that that's really a huge problem
I think you can learn to do it's a
different programming style for sure but
you can learn to deal with that that
style of programming um I think the the
doubt that would be the made the most
the largest complaint the the second
largest complaint is the the point that
node is a single threaded deal
so I mean yeah you the you can't get
node to be scheduled to multiple CPUs
right so you you can't if you have this
server you can't you can't
naively take advantage of all the cores
on your system but we have ways of doing
dealing with that actually by I mean we
have a method of doing pre fork servers
and passing the server file descriptor
between processes and accepting
connections on each of them
I do think as I as I said what the next
big thing for note is that there is some
work to do with organizing these
multiple processes and making that
easier and more approachable and
possibly more native to note one thing I
didn't talk about with Windows is that
is that one minute 30 seconds okay one
thing I didn't talk about with Windows
is that Windows really hates processes
and they don't it's not clear to us
right now how we are going to do the pre
fork server thing on Windows because you
can't actually do the iocp except on
multiple processes on the same file
descriptor in Windows there's some
trickery that we can do by having
another thread and using select just for
accepting sockets and then you know you
can you can kind of get that into the
main iocp event loop but that's not what
Windows wants you to do they they want
you to have multiple threads in one
process and use iocp to dispatch to to
these threads so one thing that's
happening in in v8 3.2 which is the
version right after us we're pegged to
3.1 right now is they're doing a v8
there they have a new feature called
isolates which is basically you know
they used a lot of global variables and
now they're all packaging them up into
into an object so that you can start
multiple VMs inside of one process so
these VMs are thick right I mean they're
they're ten megabytes or something right
they they don't share anything which is
fine but that could be used and they're
going to use this on Chrome we could use
it to to start multiple v8 inside one
process and use iocp to to schedule the
isolates onto threads as they become
available
that would be the Windows II way to do
it but we also don't want to get too far
away from how UNIX does it so it's
unclear if we should split the
implementation or you know on on UNIX
you use multiple processes on on Windows
you use multiple threads or if we should
just try to port this threading idea to
unikz threads I mean kids these days no
I don't know um okay well I guess I'm
getting booted off so uh so thank you